[Música]
de pronto sin que nadie esté preparado
una tremenda pandemia nos arrancó de
nuestro mundo aula de cuerpo presente de
tiza de pizarrón de recreo de ruido de
alumnos y nos obligó a una continuidad
pedagógica de nuestra casa con lo que
teníamos sin estar preparados sobre todo
con herramientas que nos dieron los
directivos
buscaste en youtube en facebook haciendo
lo que podías y esto generó en casi
todos frustraciones miedos errores mucha
ansiedad pero bueno acá estoy para
ayudarte esa es la idea te voy a
transmitir cómo podemos motivar a esa
especie de distancia virtual cómo
podemos motivar a nuestros alumnos y
sobre todo lo más interesante de todo te
voy a dar 18 claves ideas para que
mantengas la motivación y la atención
desde la virtualidad desde dónde estás
desde la comodidad de tu casa vale bueno
me acompañan vamos entonces vamos a
iniciar este camino para aprender todas
estas técnicas
los espero vamos
en nuestro nuevo mundo aula este
rectángulo desde nuestra casa y bueno yo
les dije antes que vamos a ver 18 claves
ideas para poder aplicar en el aula para
motivar a tus alumnos y para tener
presencia corporal no es cierto y usted
dijeron 18 claves en 15 minutos y cómo
me las voy a acordar pero bueno
tranquilos acuérdense que esta charla en
los próximos días va a estar en la
página web de 'the de x pura vida así
que ahí van a tener tiempo de escribir
anotar criticar que tranquilos bueno
arranquemos vamos la primera cosa que es
obvio es que todos los docentes de este
siglo sabíamos que las tics las
tecnologías de información de
comunicación eran fundamentales a la
hora de enseñar era una herramienta muy
importante pero de ahí a un día al otro
transformarnos todos en especialistas en
tics es otro es otro mundo y así
quedamos no trabajando muchas más horas
durmiendo poco con estrés angustia
ansiedad no es tan así
yo estoy así pero bueno vamos a empezar
a entender algo que nuestros estudiantes
hicimos nativos digitales eran nativos
digitales para jugar para participar en
las redes sociales pero no son nativos
digitales a la hora de usar herramientas
para aprender estudiar para buscar
información en redes que sean críticas y
en un buen contexto así que tranquilos
ellos también están sintiendo ansiedad e
incertidumbre también están estresados
igual que vos sientan que todos todos
estamos en un mismo barco en este barco
de la educación virtual de esta pandemia
tan tremenda sientan que por primera vez
vamos todos unidos por un mismo hecho sí
y eso nos tiene que ayudar mucho a la
hora de armar todo lo que hagamos y
además no se olvide y esto también es
muy importante que a todos nos agarró
esta pandemia de golpe en nuestras casas
con lo que teníamos algunos tienen
computadoras espectaculares otras tienen
computadoras viejas algunos tienen
celulares otros tienen celulares malos o
no tienen ninguna de las dos cosas
está bien esta desigualdad existe y la
tenemos que tener en cuenta cuando
armemos contenidos con dormimos no
usemos herramientas de pensar lo que
quisieran lo puedan usar ahora lo pueden
usar después no nos olvidemos de ellos
también sí así que bueno lo que sí
también es positivo además de que no
eran tan nativos digitales en algunos
aspectos es que estas herramientas si
consideran el alumno un eje prioritario
y además piensa en una cosa no regulen
por primera vez su propio tiempo de
aprendizaje que significa antes los
hacíamos entrar de 8 de la mañana a 12
del mediodía oa la tarde les imponemos
un horario para estudiar o para aprender
ahora ellos pueden manejar sus tiempos y
buscar cuando esto le funciona mejor si
aprovechar ese tiempo para estudiar más
allá de que obviamente vos organiza
alguna charla sincrónica y bueno y ellos
tengan que cumplir un horario pero el
resto del tiempo
van poder ellos elegir cuándo hacerlo y
a partir de ahí es que las herramientas
que armes que diseñes deben tratar de
despertar el interés la motivación la
constancia de que él se siente en su
nueva aula hacerlo por eso es que ahí
van algunos consejos que te pueden
ayudar para lograr esto sí y este es el
objetivo de mi charla y piensen un
poquito que lo primero que tenemos que
tratar de imitar ahora es que en este
nuevo mundo público de los dos lados
esté algo parecido a lo que vivimos en
el aula no esa es un poquito la idea la
materialidad del espacio que hay que el
que era lo más lindo del aula que
conversábamos que discutíamos que nos
reíamos que nos mirábamos que no
solíamos bueno como lo gran parte de eso
acá y fíjense que las primeras pruebas
claves van a tratar de eso de cómo
tratar de tener cuerpos de los dos lados
esa es mi primera idea vamos vamos
entonces vamos la primera 18 vamos a la
primera
es obviamente la caja para mí es
fundamental siempre el aula también tu
cara tu cara debe estar bien clara en lo
que haces se debe ver bien y acá empieza
un lío bastante común que nuestro
cerebro está acostumbrado a hablar a
otra cara no han agujerito de una cámara
ese es un problema entonces
continuamente cuando tomamos este tipo
de diseños educativos estamos mirando un
costado a los vídeos de los alumnos a lo
que nos ayuda a nuestras notas para
ayudarnos a recordar y no no estamos
mirándolos a ellos por eso nunca te
olvides que para armar una comunicación
ojo con ojo acá también tiene que
existir este engaño de pensar que este
agujerito son los ojos de tus alumnos
y por lo tanto por lo tanto por ejemplo
miren lo que me dicen yo yo ahí donde
tengo mi cámara puse una cabeza unos
ojos que me miran y eso me ayuda a mirar
todo el tiempo ahí sí entonces es la
primera clave que sería tu cara y además
la segunda gran clave la segunda y para
muchos es la más importante en la voz la
voz tu voz tiene que ser fuerte clara
que cambien los tonos sí y sobre todo
que tengas un buen micrófono que nos
escuche teclado que no se escuchan los
ruidos de tu nueva aún así tu voz tiene
que ser imponente en este momento porque
a veces tu carita se ve chiquita pero tu
voz invade este espacio virtual y además
que otra cosa corporal tu voz tu cara
tus gestos sus gestos tienes que
aumentarlos tienes que ser más exagerado
pues te de chiquito entonces tu gesto
que comunican tanto tus cejas tus ojos
tu boca tu risa acércate aleja
y tratar de que se vean tus manos tus
gestos ahora son fundamentales estas
sencillas son las tres más importantes
en cuanto a lo corporal de este de este
lado pero piensen también en lo corporal
del otro a ver nuestros alumnos
caminaban hacia las aulas hacia los
colegios hacia las universidades siguen
un tiempo donde podían relajarse reírse
en los pasillos ahora de golpe se
sientan y te empiezan a mirar entonces
lo primero que tenés que hacer y como
cuarta clave es tranquilizar esos
cuerpos o sea no puedes empezar
directamente con tu clase tienes que
empezar con algo de humor con leer un
cuento pequeño preguntarles cómo están
poner alguna música hacer mindfulness
respiración lo que vos quieras pero
tranquiliza sus cuerpos acuérdense que
en un cuerpo contracturado ansioso y
estresado el cerebro no funcionaría para
tómate ese tiempo tómate ese tiempo y
además pensar ahora que esa aula que
estamos usando es nueva por lo tanto los
alumnos si deben prepararla no puede ser
que la computadora todavía está en el
niño que está en la cocina donde estaba
antes o no puede ser que se tiene a la
cama con los celulares a estudiar si
este es un momento donde les tenemos que
enseñar que el ambiente debe ser como
una buena mesa con agua con luz con aire
sin pedirles al resto de la casa que en
ese momento nos dejen tranquilos que nos
dejen estudiar que no dejen atender
enséñales a mejorar ese nuevo ambiente
si vamos a la sexta participación
corporal activa como en el aula que
participan en los chats de las
aplicaciones que participan hablando en
el micrófono que participen dibujando
que participen con sus cuerpos que hagan
aprendizajes colaborativos con mucha
participación si por otro lado si
importantísimo como clave 7 noten su
presencia pero también noten su ausencia
significa esto que que feliciten los
cuando participan y además si no
participan mucho o si nos vienen a
nuestras clases escribamos un correo que
lindo que un docente sienta que no estás
acá es también es muy motivador
escribamos le un correo digamos por qué
no estuviste o por qué participa este
poquito está bien y obviamente otra
forma también de que se mueven es que
obliguemos los a tomar apuntes a tomar
notas de lo que están escuchando de lo
que están mirando el apunte que hacen
mover el cuerpo el apunte te hace
sintetizar y sobre todo que dibujen y
hagan esquemas es mucho más importante
para la memoria del dibujo y el esquema
la letra cursiva pero las tres cosas son
importantes sí y por último casi de esto
de lo corporal si despertar la
curiosidad despertar la curiosidad del
asombro si tu clase debe empezar con
algo que les despierte la curiosidad y
por qué no empieces directamente con el
tema ni repasando despertar la
curiosidad de tus alumnos despertar que
hagan interesante lo que vamos a ver yo
le dije vamos a ver 18 claves entonces
si ustedes están vamos quiero verlas es
sólo tener lo primero tengo que hacer un
buen título algo que despierte su
curiosidad y no te olvides que somos
seres sociales siempre tanto en el aula
presencial como en la virtual que hagan
cosas juntos y hagan trabajos juntos por
favor que tomarles evaluaciones juntos
acordate que estar bien con otras
personas el primer paso de la felicidad
sigue este es un momento donde el
trabajo colaborativo tiene que ser
y esencial y que más como clave 11 nunca
uses un solo canal no podés estar 40
minutos una hora solo hablando de
biología de matemáticas qué significa
esto cada tanto que aparezca algo
distinto usa otro canal algo llamativo
eso genera sorpresa acordate que la
sorpresa en la clave del aprendizaje el
sorprendi za je que decía un amigo ramón
barrera la sorpresa es la clave del
aprendizaje usa otros canales cada tanto
para despertar ese cerebro y esa
atención que es única una es que los
despertar con algo que aparece este es
el único tuyo
el alumno queda atrapado en lo que si te
olvides de eso nunca uses un solo canal
aburre ya casi en esta época algo
fundamental repensar los contenidos no
vamos a volver al aula y no es el aula
presencial basta de llenarlos de
contenidos
- y bien mucho mejor que mucho rápido y
mal sus momentos para repensar lo que
estamos haciendo al parar un poco por
favor esta clave es creo que una de las
más importantes porque es una de las que
más está afecta
nuestros alumnos y alumnas y hay que
darlo importa
estamos si recorta un poco si es el
momento para repensar los contenidos que
estás dando y por último de mis claves
la retroalimentación positiva sagrada
continuamente yo miro los nombres de mis
alumnos sí y les digo muy bien lo que
hiciste muy bien lo que comentaste con
nombre y apellido así los demás quieren
sentir eso la retroalimentación positiva
continua en la virtualidad aunque hagas
algo a sincrónico si en esa sincrónico
si te mandaron un trabajo de siglo
comentario mencionarlos con nombre ahí
los tenés ahora en las nuevas las
aplicaciones salen todos los nombres de
tus alumnos aprovecharlo retroalimentar
los que es muy positivo y si tenés algo
negativo siempre por chat nunca en
público no obviamente por otro lado por
otro lado les quiero comentar que hay un
montón de claves sobre todo las que más
me han gustado son las que comparte gres
wilson si un investigador de datos de
voz
y quiero compartirlas con ustedes porque
me gustaron mucho la primera no es
tenemos a sillas vacías esa me encantó
claro tratemos de hacer cosas sin
crónicas y ver los vídeos de nuestros
alumnos porque en esos vídeos más allá
de que estamos mirando a la cámara y
cada tanto los miramos a ellos vemos sus
caritas que están contentos si están
participando se están aburriendo y esto
nos motiva por eso nunca hay que enseñar
a sillas vacías nunca sí y otra clave
que habla dre es que no hay que tener
que ser suposiciones de los materiales
que tienen ellos de cómo manejan las
herramientas de la tecnología que maneja
antes de empezar a usar una nueva
herramienta primero hagamos una encuesta
si ellos la pueden usar o no si tienen
la posibilidad de usarla si y por otro
lado antes de empezar a usarla ella de
dar clase con ella practiquemos la nada
más horrible que se te desconecta que no
ande la voz que no la sepa manejar está
bien eso desmotiva
no te olvides de eso sí ten en cuenta y
recordad recordar que hay una
desigualdad tecnológica por eso pensar
mucho en lo sincrónico también o si
haces algo sincrónico grabarlo para
después compartirlo con aquellos que no
pudieron estar con vos
y asociado a esta hay algo que dice greg
que me encantó que me gustó mucho
pensemos que en el mundo la mayor parte
de los alumnos y alumnas tienen
celulares y que casi todos están viendo
nuestras clases con celulares por eso
armamos armemos los contenidos para
pantallas chicas así que tus
presentaciones de powerpoint si no
tengan tanto texto que las imágenes sean
grandes que tu alumno pueda ver bien en
esa pantalla porque si ve mal se va a
desmotivar no te olvides de eso sí y por
último ahora si la 18
aprende la canción antes de improvisar o
sea practica mucho primero con la
herramienta con todo antes de ponerte a
probar y fallar más allá de que el error
es parte de la pedagogía pero una cosa
es el error por no haber practicado ese
error no estamos de acuerdo
a practicar las herramientas antes de
usarlas muchos practicarlas incluso para
que no fallen porque si pasan
continuamente en la clase desmotiva
muchísimo
y ahora sí
voy terminando y récord récord en algo
que todos todos en algún momento hemos
sido malos para algo para empezar a ser
buenos no pasa nada si te equivocas si
no sabes es un momento como espectacular
para experimentar si es el momento para
apropiarse de esas herramientas pero
recordar que esas herramientas son sólo
una ayuda que lo presencial que ya vamos
a volver al aula que son una ayuda y que
como dice daniel brailovsky las bondades
de las herramientas dependerán del
criterio de las personas que las usan
eso es muy importante no no es que no
vamos a volver y que ahora de ahora en
más las clases van a ser así no es
verdad hay que repensar la educación y
yo digo en los contenidos que uses
tengan aire que significa aire a de que
sean asombrosos atrapantes y de que sean
importantes por favor si recordemos los
contenidos
relevantes sobre todo relevantes a este
contexto por favor que tengan mucho aire
nunca hubo un momento como esto como
éste nunca en serio sientan lo inunda
por eso
[Música]